[The sound of strong winds]
The wind is making it extremely uncomfortably cold
It is probably between -10 and -15 [degrees celcius]
We just had -27 a couple of weeks ago
In general when the wind picks up
it's really really cold
My name is Andreas
My name is Johannes
I'm in Norway
I'm on the Field Quality Engineering team
just a couple of kilometers below the Arctic Circle
This week we're gonna take a Model Y through Norway
and see how it performs on a customer level
and customer expectations
Testing is important because we can predict
what the customer will experience
when they are actually driving here
The weather can be super local around here
We have no crosswinds at all right now
and then three kilometers down the road
you suddenly have 40 km/h crosswinds
So it's a very common scenario for Norway
where people live in the city close by the Sea
and then basically go up to the mountain
to their cabins over the weekend
The water that accumulates around the car
maybe around the wipers
or around the wheels will tend to freeze
and we still need to have a car
that performs well under those conditions
[Calm music]
[The sound of squeaking snow]
That it's slippery
We're trying to replicate customer scenarios
and finding all the challenges with driving a car
in the northern Scandinavian parts
For this trip we have equipped taillights
with a humidity temperature and pressure sensor
to measure what the interior of the light actually withstands
during the mountain climbs
and the tunnel temperature differences
Lasse actually made a super good simple setup
which I think is one of the strengths
of the Field Quality Engineering team
that we can do a lot with little
[Calm music continues]
Now we're for a brief moment in the workshop
to inspect a couple of things
that is difficult to do alongside the road
and we try to do it quickly
to not dry or heat up the car too much
because we want to have it outside as much as we can
Now I'm inspecting the the wiper washer hoses
The typical day up here
is a very harsh environment for the cars
because you have a lot of temperature differences
as well as elevation changes
so you can really stress the car in this area
simulating a complete winter in a couple of weeks
This testing hopefully means that we can increase
durability and reliability of our product
and that it will work in any scenario
anywhere in the world
[Upbeat music]